[Music]
foreign
let's go ahead and let the people in to
our daily with Doc Zoom open up the
doors
hello everybody
hope you are having a absolutely
fabulous day as we are here bringing
encouragement empowerment and knowledge
to the masses my name is Becca Dukes as
the hostess of this program daily with
Doc we want to be a resource that
empowers you that puts more helpful
Tools in your toolbox to allow you to be
able to reach your optimal best that's
optimal best in health and wellness
mental physical spiritual Mind Body
Financial all the above folks and for us
we are using nutrition to strengthen the
whole entire body soap we can one think
right
two
have that positive feeling that allows
us to be able to attract others that are
positive and
also be able to have the health to enjoy
life
no matter where we're at in life if we
don't have health and we're hurting it
just it has this negative Shadow on
everything else we do and the only
reason why I say this is because I was
there
and now I am absolutely loving life
loving what I am able to do because I
have found health and wellness and it's
all because of the doctor that we
highlight on this program Monday through
Friday from 12 to 12 50 p.m almost every
day
except the fact that he is getting ready
to travel and then we'll have a couple
days off well you'll have a couple days
off I won't have a couple days off but
folks it's a message that needs to make
it around the world and have a positive
impact and and just taking back your own
health
so listen up as we are bringing
information to you I do want to I have
to remind you this program is for
educational purposes only on the
importance of nutrition our products are
not diagnosed to prevented or diagnose
any diseases but folks
through the research of the doctor that
we have with us today
three post-doctorates in pathology
with some big
big cases or what would you call them
studies Dr Wallach Lance
I'm sorry grants so the grants yeah the
grants supported your your work
but we're talking about
National Institute for health NIH the
NIH yes thank you Dr Wallach but what
I'm trying to say is folks it's not just
a one or two species we're talking 400
over 452 species and it's not just one
or two of each species we're talking one
one
Excursion Excursion is not the right
word
where he was looking at 1700 children
that had died
and then to try to figure out what is
that underlying cause it doesn't just
happen children are supposed to be
healthy they're supposed to have
vibrancy in their life what caused these
children
to no longer have breath
and that is one of the things that Dr
Wallach has taken his research from and
linked each category of the body
how nutrition plays in each category in
the body and most importantly how
deficiencies affect each part of the
body and then
he couldn't find a solution
for that
so he created one
created a solution and
as a with having a Bachelor of Science
in agriculture uh
doctor of veterinary medicine his three
post doctorates he wanted to be able to
bring this information to the human race
so he went on to become a naturopathic
physician so that he could actually
legally treat humans as well
he brought his work he brought his
formulas to us and making a positive
impact in letting people have that hope
that they don't have to be chemical
dependent because folks we're not
chemical deficient or nutrient deficient
so without further Ado if you were
shared this program by anybody specific
make sure that you get back with them
thank them for the information that you
are about to hear and as you are
listening if you're live with us make
sure that you have that chat open
because I have some amazing co-hosts one
of them does absolutely fabulous
dictation and puts the information into
the chat so it makes it easier to follow
along because Dr Wallach he does speak
quite quickly and I'm going to ask him
just to slow down a little bit
so that she doesn't have to work so hard
um but if you missed something that he
said you can go to our website or you
can find us out on YouTube or rumble or
Spotify or
all these different platforms parlor I'm
gonna have to get the list right there
so I can go through the list
because I want to welcome each and
everyone where you are because we're
here for you wherever it is that you are
in the around the world
but
what I was trying to say if you're not
with us in the live zoom and you want to
see that chat then go ahead and go to
daily with
doczoom.com join us here in the live
zoom and if you have a question that you
would like to ask Dr Wallach go to that
Zoom menu and find the reactions and
raise your hand we do have this as an
interactive Zoom that's why we invite
you in if you've got questions we want
to make sure that you get answers from
the man himself so please raise your
hand we've got a lot of people here with
us I'm sure somebody has questions and I
will be calling on them in the order
that their hands is raised we also have
people that are watching the comments so
I have again my amazing co-hosts out
watching each of the platforms if you
have questions they bring the questions
into the zoom time permitting we will
get through them and if we do not get to
your question go to daily with
stock.com we have an option where you
can submit your questions there make
sure that you sign up for our newsletter
and you're also going to find in the
menu the 10 Good Foods bad foods list
that Dr Wallach speaks of you're also
going to find a store but that store is
for those who do not already have
somebody that they are working with
and for those who do not have somebody
that they are working with they've never
had the products they have never heard
Dr Wallach or nobody referred them to
Pure Dr Wallach I also have a call team
available at 855-949
-3377 so now without further Ado it is
my honor and privilege to present to you
and bring to the screen with me Dr Joel
Wallach hello Dr Wallach welcome well
hello and thank you Rebecca thank you
thank you for the kind introduction and
the sort of layout to people who are new
that's very helpful to them I'm sure
and um today we want to talk about
something that's very important to
everybody okay everybody has a heart
okay and it works 24 7. when you're
asleep it's working you're eating it's
working when you're working at work it's
working uh when your exercise is working
okay when you're taking a nap it's
working and so it never stops you hope
it stops you're dead Okay and so um just
treating the symptoms of heart disease
not preventing or curing it uh we spend
in America each year
316.8 billion dollars just to treat the
symptoms of heart disease
high blood pressure we spend 131 billion
dollars
okay so that's about 450 billion right
there between heart disease and high
blood pressure then you throw in kidney
disease okay which has to do with blood
pressure and circulation most people
don't realize that
that's 24 billion so you're getting
pretty close there to
[Music]
um that
uh four billion 400 billion dollars okay
for the heart disease public pressure
and kidney disease
and so we have to take care of it and
one of my favorite stories of course is
the work we did with Evander Holyfield
great great heavyweight boxing champion
he won a lot lost the title several
times
and um let's see here
uh I'll get this wrong but he was in a a
fight defending his title it was a
12-round fight I'll schedule 12 rounds
and he was fighting against Michael
Moore Michael Moore I think that's
correct Michael Moore
and
um and the the
um
break before the last round
he has an issue with his heart
okay and an issue with his heart and
there's all kinds of arguments what he
had what he didn't have and so forth but
he couldn't continue and he lost his
championship by default to Michael Moore
okay because he couldn't answer the Bell
for the 12th round the final round
and um you know my dad was a a Golden
Gloves champion in boxing I spent a lot
of time in the boxing gymnasiums and
training sites and stuff like that as a
result and became a pretty good boxer
just because I was watching the others
and had access to all their equipment
and their trainers and so forth they
thought to hear this little kid four or
five years old learning how to box was
kind of cute
but anyway
um
the point that I'm making we're already
working with um professional
athletations so he came up with the
healthy brain and heart pack for Evander
Holyfield we got him on it for a couple
of months and and by then
um Michael Moore had lost his
championship to Mike Tyson who's much
more aggressive much more volatile
Champion than Michael Moore was
and so anyway after just like 90 days on
our healthy brain and heart pack okay we
also at that time had the rebounder
sports drink
um Evander Holyfield comes back
and he
um just about annihilates Mike Tyson
who's one of the toughest heavyweight
champions ever
and so the referees had to jump in and
stop the fight in his sixth round
because Mike Tyson had
excuse me had had gotten to the point
where he couldn't defend himself anymore
Evander Holyfield became Champion again
and so this is very very interesting
stuff it all has to do with nutrition
okay the body needs nutrition for your
lungs your skin your intestines your
brain your thyroid gland but also for
the heart and the blood vessels and also
for the kidneys and so this is something
that as Rebecca said if you want to be
healthy and you want to be able to enjoy
life for a long time you have to take
care of the parts just like you do your
car you put oil in your car you put
antifreeze in the car you have
um the fluid for the the windshield
wipers you have brake fluid and so on
you don't just put dirt from Texas in
your car and hope that there's
everything you need for your car because
it's dirt from Texas there's bound to be
some oil in there people aren't that
silly so they cheat they treat their car
much better than they treat themselves
so he came up with these programs and
you know we do have books and CDs and
all that kind of stuff we have a new
tool coming out here pretty soon so you
get the pricing on it
um it's a flip chart 72 Pages it'll
allow everybody even if you've only been
with us for one day to put on a
a presentation
that is at the level which doctors and
phds will and pharmacists will be
impressed
okay and so the flip chart is going to
be available here pretty soon as soon as
we get the pricing on it
we're very excited about that and
um and so we're kind of getting back to
what do you need to make your heart
healthy and happy
you need 90 essential nutrients your
heart needs 90 essential nutrients 90.
not two matches vitamin C okay people so
I take a lot of them like vitamin C well
that's fine but you need the other 89
too okay and we you know unbeknownst to
ourselves
prior to the Advent of electricity we
were getting mineral supplements by
putting our wood ashes and coal ashes
into our Gardens and putting them into
our food as a spice
and we're the vegetables were absorbing
the minerals out of the wood ashes of
coal ash and we eat those vegetables we
get our minerals that way we went to
electricity there's no more access to
minerals in our food
plants don't make minerals nutritional
minerals are not occurring uniform blank
around the trust of the earth they turn
in veins like gold and silver the people
who live the longest on Earth right now
are the hunzas and the Himalayan
Mountains their life expectancy is 120
many lives be 130 140 150 they don't
have any medical doctors but they do
have the land flowing with milk and
honey that's that's the glacial milk
coming down from the mountains which say
fertilize their Gardens with okay and
they drink it and they cook with it and
so forth and then
um we have electricity we no longer have
easy access from for
minerals in our food as we did when we
were using wood answers and coal ashes
in our food as spices and also in our
Gardens as fertilizer
there is no
access to
vitamins and minerals when you use
electricity
and so you do have to consciously
proactively supplement to make sure
you're giving everything you need to
every cell in your body including your
heart which works 24 7. okay for your
entire life it's working when you're an
embryo okay and so you really really
want to take good care of that heart and
again we do have
um
the healthy brain and heart pack we
named it for that because we want people
to know that you if you want I only
weigh 142 pounds and I take two of those
per month take a full dose or anything
twice a day
and then
um I also I take extra of the things
they're going to make my heart Happy
okay and that includes our ultimate
daily classic tablets the ultimate daily
classic talents sort of support healthy
blood
flow through blocked arteries whether
it's in your your brain your heart your
lungs your liver your kidneys supports
healthy blood pressure
and then we have all these antioxidants
okay we have the things that make your
your body happy okay and prevent
diseases from inflammation okay we have
the antioxidants and this we have the
rebound or Sports Drinker that has a
hundred nutrients in it 75 minerals and
25 bonds amino acids so we're giving it
all access to all these ways to support
all your tissues particularly the heart
and your blood vessels okay and if you
do that you can add 25 to 50 Health
years to your life
and um this is a you know again Evander
Holyfield is still alive and still going
strong because of our healthy brain and
heart pack which we made for him and
brought him out of the jaws of death
okay and so we're very very proud of
that story okay over to you Becca
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
um yeah the heart everybody has one
is
there a song about that you got to have
heart
yes that's right
absolutely so you got to have heart if
you don't have heart if you don't have a
strong heart then it's not going to be
strong and it's going to affect your
life all over
so whether you have a low
pulse rate or a high pulse rate we want
to make sure that it is what it is
supposed to be for you and by doing that
and giving the body the nutrition that
it deserves and the oxygen
and the antioxidants no and oxygen
because it pumps the oxygen
there's every cell in your body
that's right
that's right so and that ties right in
with the loans and the need for
essential fatty acids for the lungs to
bring in the oxygen to give it put it in
the blood for the heart to pump it all
over the place it's not just one or two
things folks that you need
90 essential nutrients and if you've
already started down that decline Dr
Wallach he and that's why he always
mentions the brain and heart pack the
biggest hammer in the Box
as far as a foundation right because it
truly is
huh so and then we have secret sauces
for say you have type 2 diabetes we have
a secret sauce for that okay see him
having pressure we have a cedar sauce
for that say you have arthritis we have
a secret sauce for that let's say you
have digestion problems we have secret
sauces for that okay let's say the
doctors have taken out your gallbladder
they really didn't need to but they did
because they needed the money they took
out your gallbladder we have a a program
for that okay and so we have
5 000 products to deal with over 600
different diseases we've been doing this
for 75 years now I started it 75 years
ago okay youngevity's only been around
for what 40 something 50 year 50 years I
think
30 years 35 years well yeah it's fun and
get an exact date yeah it was it was
American Longevity for many years before
yeah okay
and we couldn't get into foreign
countries because they didn't want
American Longevity to come into their
country so we had to change the name to
youngeity so you're getting those
foreign countries kind of crazy politics
it is crazy politics but I'm glad that
you did it Dr Wallach because that has
introduced me to a lot of amazing people
abroad including those who are part of
our co-host team
um as we have Albert down in South
Africa
um and then on my team we've got people
in Nigeria and Bahrain and Pakistan and
Czech Republic the UK Scotland
um Columbia
just all over the place Vietnam Mexico
well yeah
I think I oh I do have one person on my
specific team but young jelly is
absolutely making an impact around the
world in being able to provide
intentional nutrition folks like Dr
Wallach said they didn't realize that
when they started with electricity and
started building those dams and then
start started messing with the whole
flow of water what that was really doing
when it came to our soils and the health
of our soils or our food is grown
so that whole cause and effect
and made a big impact and people just
don't realize it they appreciate the
convenience of electricity without even
considering what that convenience has
caused in way of depleting our food
sources
so it's you know everything that we do
is gone to either have a positive or
negative effect
well sharing this message is going to
give a positive effect Dr wallig yeah
exactly and of course they should have
said okay now with this electricity
throws responsibility on you because you
have to take all your 90 essential
nutrients because you're not getting
your 16 minerals anymore from from the
wood ashes and coal ashes like you used
to so you have to provide them for
yourself with a supplement program like
we do for animals on the farm like we do
for pet animals that's why there's
vitamins and minerals and dog food and
cat food okay because tables they don't
want you giving table scraps to the
animals because you'll kill them with
table scraps what well that's what I eat
right you don't want to be giving them
what you eat to the animals because
that's why you only live to be 50 60 70
and you watch Fox News every day there's
two or three young athletes or
politicians or or somebody actors or
actresses somebody of some recognition
and importance
having a heart attack many of them died
but there's so many who have heart
attacks because they're not getting the
nutrition they need just to maintain
the heart muscle
yeah it's
it's crazy Dr Wallach to to see that and
these are just the people that are in
the public eye that doesn't even count
for those that are not those everyday
people and that are you know walking
around thinking we're doing great and
then bam
or we think that we're doing great
because our Pharmaceuticals are masking
the symptoms yeah now that basketball
player okay
James
the one whose son just had the heart
attack oh oh LeBron's son yeah LeBron
LeBron James correct
yes okay and Ronnie James is a son okay
was he uh 16 17 18 years old something
like that he was 18. 18 yeah had a
terrible heart attack and thank God he's
out of the hospital now and he's
stabilized says that's a good thing okay
and they can't figure out why he had the
heart attack well I guarantee you he's
eating french fries and all that kind of
stuff and he was exercising because
they're saying here's a kid he's praying
he's he's playing basketball at the
professional level at 18 years of age
he's not poor so he can eat well and yet
he has his heart issue what's going on
there is it a genetic thing no I
guarantee you you know he's you know his
age or those buddies are going out and
eating french fries and drinking colas
and all that kind of stuff and who knows
what he was taking for vitamins and
minerals and we have made a
um about a seven minute
video for him and sent it to him we
haven't received any have you received
any feedback yet from Tom or not yet not
yet I haven't receive any feedback yet
we did send you a message why that heart
attack occurred and so forth and you
know if he
um puts
um brownie uh
um
on the settlements then he'll be able to
get right back and play very well and
not have to worry about a heart attack
yeah
well doctor
we just we want this message to be heard
and folks you hearing it
is part of that so please share it with
those that you know those that you love
if you have a platform to share
information on whether it's just a
Facebook and sharing it to your to your
profile whether you have your own
channels on different platforms please
feel free to share this information be
empowered
you being here and listening is not here
by accident
okay take this information and allow it
to be able to bless the lives of others
if you are an influencer or just an
everyday person and you want to get a
thank you chat for sharing this
information we have that available as
well I love my thank you checks and
it's just because I'm using my story and
how I was blessed by the nutrition that
Dr Wallach put together and the program
that he recommended for me which
I love the fact when I first spoke to
him he says I will treat you like a dog
but you will get better and I did
I really did I got better and now I'm
I'm blessed to be able to get reports
from people each and every day of how
they're getting better including one
last night is in a three-way call with
Coach Rod uh with a with a new
distributor he started on the program Dr
Wallach just three months ago he has
already lost 40 pounds starting on your
program
and he's feeling great he's his joints
aren't hurting like they were so I mean
three months and 40 pounds that's
fabulous I only lost 20 in three months
but the fact that it's duplicatable is
even better
but it takes finding
your worth and how you are worth
intentional supplementation
we've got another good report Dr Wallach
and Carrie is on with us and she reports
um
that well she's not ready for Cameron
she's got the dogs barking but the fact
that she has this dog barking who her
German Shepherd
um gets what the vet calls seasonal
allergies every summer chews her skin
bloody at the hip and back leg joints
especially seasonal allergy shots were
costing her a hundred dollars per month
she added in the arthro decks it got
better she added the I-26 and as of
today not chewing hips or legs this has
been a yearly battle every summer
coordinated with when she blows out her
winter coat to her summer coat she was
concerned
um
that oh I'm concerned that it's not a
skin issue but thought maybe a joint
issue so thankful I got I-26 for the
humans to have on hand so good reports
arthrodex giving that nutrition and the
enzymes
that our animals need because we kind of
think forget about that part of it Dr
Wallach
you've got your vitamins you've got your
amino acids you've got your minerals
oh we forget about the enzymes that help
break down the food and if the digestive
system is shot
then the gallbladder is not making the
enzymes that are needed to break down
the fats so that we can have those fat
soluble vitamins absorbed
so folks
I had a question here um somebody asked
if the nutrient to treat
um one of your favorite conditions right
now Dr Wallach Parkinson's is found in
the Beyond tingy tangerine
it's not just a single nutrient it's
correct this is a whole system okay it
would be the healthy Brandon hard pack
for for Parkinson's Disease it held a
brand hard pack the I-26
um synaptive
MSM
although daily classic tablets for
circulation
and
let's start there
all right and then
um Raphael has a question in regards to
uh he he works out five days a week
and he wants to know how much rebound he
should take he's been taking half the
dose in the morning and then a full dose
with his workout or after his workout as
a recovery and wants to know if if
that's sufficient to help maintain
muscle and of course the 90 essential
nutrients are going to be the most
important and the rebound is just one of
those secret sauces to help is that
correct that's right it's a secret sauce
because of your workout your sweat and
people drink a lot of water after they
work out to rehydrate and that's why
they die okay because the sweat is more
than just water it's a soup that
contains vitamins and minerals in it if
you're just drinking water rehydrate
after you exercise and not taking extra
supplements well that's why we came up
with the rebound that was for SEO
Ratliff we already made the healthy Bone
and Joint pack for him and regroup all
of his joints and his cartilage and
everything like that and got him back on
the basketball court
but he you know he was wearing out and
so we came up with the rebound or as
horse trained for him I only weigh 142
pounds and I like to take two doses a
day I'll take a full dose of breakfast
and then half a dose at lunch time in
the second half of the second dose the
rest of the afternoon some drinking
rebound all through the day and
the rebound has 100 nutrients in it 75
minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids Red
Bull
the biggest seller energy drink on the
market only has one mineral magnesium
okay and they they give you energy
through sugar and caffeine
we give you energy through providing
what your various tissues your muscles
and your hearts and your lungs and your
liver kidneys and everything else and
blood vessels what they need to perform
at Optimum and so we're coming at it
from a different direction than just
sugar and caffeine like Red Bull does
yeah we're we're a more holistic
way of doing it folks
it's not just this for that you get it
and we're supporting systems activities
yes
now Bob has a question Dr Wallach in
regards to leaky gut
so leaky gut
a little bit about what leaky gut is
what the cause of it is and what are
your recommendations for addressing it
okay leaky gut
um which I say it um it tells you kind
of a story and it's a term given to a
an event going on the doctors really
didn't know the answer to so they just
called it leaky gut because it put food
and dye and tracers in the mouth and it
all come out the other end
okay so they call it leaky gut because
say everything's coming out the other
end as opposed to being absorbed this is
due to a gluten issue okay and so what
you want to do is get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed Meats
no oils no glutens no wheatening bar
around oats
um let's see here no buckwheat there's
no gluten in buckwheat but it does have
phagopirings f-a-g-o-pairings which are
ten times worse than gluten no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the carbonated
diet drinks got to go and carbonate
water got to go because they neutralize
stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals or digest food then in addition
to taking the healthy brain and heart
pack one per 100 pounds of body weight
taking MSM
um one bottle of months per 100 pounds
of body weight a minimum of three twice
a day the collagen peptides are scuba
that twice a day and then the ultimate
enzymes we call it the gallbladder in a
bottle the ultimate enzymes I like to
take two or three of those depending on
your body weight I take two or three
um say 10 15 minutes for each meal and
that helps you absorb all the various
nutrients and um
the fact that you're giving up all the
bad stuff the good food bad foods very
important we do have a book Dr while
he's cooking without the bad foods it's
300 pages of of um there you go 300
pages of healthy cooking and and um
recipes healthy recipes and it also has
a good food bad food list in that book
okay so everybody needs that but um the
leaky gut syndrome you should be able to
get rid of that in just a couple of
weeks get rid of all the bad stuff
take your 90 essential nutrients take
your
um
uh let's see here take your enzymes take
the ultimate enzymes which we call the
gallbladder in a bottle we do called the
gallbladder bottle because we go to the
slaughterhouse we take the gallbladders
from all the cows they kill for make
steaks we take the gallbladder as we dry
the bile that's in there and put bile in
all of our enzymes I think we're the
only company that puts bile in our
enzyme so that's why we call it the
gallbladder in a bottle and so you'll be
amazed at the difference okay
so leaky gut syndrome is easy to get rid
of because it's not a genetic thing it's
just a bad diet bad habits which are
easily
resolves
so with leaky gut doctor while he said
that it's a it's a gluten intolerance
okay so we remove the gluten yeah
that's right yep we use the nutrition
including the enzymes to help clear the
the residual the gooeyness that's Caked
Up on all of the Villi within the
intestines
the enzymes help do that that allows
better absorption of the nutrients
because it's getting all that surface
re-exposed so that you can absorb
instead of having it coated because
think about it folks if if you put a
coating over
plastic okay say your plastic coat some
metal
what does that plastic coating do
it protects that metal from oxygen well
think of it as in your digestive system
you've got that glutinous gooey coating
over your intestines which is it's not
really protecting the Villi it's
suffocating them
and it's preventing them from doing
their job yeah your intestine should
look like a shag rug with all those
Villages sticking up it should look like
a shag rug but when you have
um this
um it's leaky gut syndrome okay your
intestines now look like a plastic tube
you've lost 90 percent of your
absorptive surface as you can point out
because all this gooey stuff is covering
those villi
yeah so we want to make sure that we're
giving the body the best opportunity to
absorb as much as absolutely possible
folks
because without those nutrients
uh you're gonna have to climb it's just
kind of guaranteed you take away what's
needed what happens and anything and
everything in life you don't preserve
your home what happens
it starts to break down the repairs are
costly prevention is the best way to go
folks so whether you're sick or not it
doesn't matter you still need the 90
essential nutrients and Dr Wallach
invites you to give him 90 days
to get on a program and you will
definitely feel a difference in fact Dr
Wallach we have a whole crew of people
you are one of the founding fathers of
The Institute of holistic health that
teaches about your research about those
four areas of Health how they're
affected by deficiencies and then using
the youngevity products as a solution
that's available to anybody and
everybody
yeah you can go to coachwithdoc.com
and you'll get more information about
the certified holistic health coach
course whether you're using it for
yourself or using it to build a coaching
business we welcome you all because
knowledge is power what were you going
to say Dr Wallace I'm gonna say let's go
back to the turn of the 20th century to
1900.
um dogs pet dogs in the home their
average life expectancy was four to five
years
now when they came out was canned dog
food based on
50 years of lab research and
universities on dog diets okay they're
looking at nutrition but they use dogs
as a laboratory animals so they had lots
of information
what they found out was when they added
all these vitamins and minerals to the
dog food
now the dogs are living to be
12 to 15 years of age instead of five
and so that's why you see canned dog
food with all the vitamins and minerals
in there okay that's based on research
it goes back to to
1890 in 1880 and that sort of stuff
that's when they're starting to do
research like that and so we we can't
thank the dog food companies enough for
for being proactive back in those days
and this is how I learned to take care
of myself I was dealing with the farm
animals and I started eating farm animal
food and I healed myself from many
different issues including emotional
things and
where I was actually beating up people
and stuff like that and I also had stuff
going on with my joints and so forth and
I was able to I just started eating
animal food with all the vitamins and
minerals in it and it all went away and
that's what I knew and that's why I told
you when we met I was going to treat you
like a dog but you're going to get
better because
I I was using the concept and I wasn't
using dog food but I was using the
concept of dog food by putting vitamins
and minerals into your food okay which
was the land flowing with milk and honey
okay and so it all kind of came together
yes absolutely absolutely well Dr
Wallach let's go to Ruth Ellen who has
her hand up Ruth Ellen
go ahead and unmute yourself you're on
live with Dr Wallach come on Dr Wallach
and hello everybody happy to see you all
I have a gentleman who is 64 years old
he weighs 220 pounds and he's five foot
ten
he is mostly gluten-free except he
drinks beer
um and he's changed his diet
um to the carnivore diet so he doesn't
eat grains and stuff like that um
he has tinnitus and he's had it since 16
years old and it's very bad and tonight
is ringing in ears yes tinnitus and he's
got colitis and and a couple other
things but a couple of those things went
away he's been taking the Ultimate
Classic liquid
um because he is on a strict budget
um but he's wondering
what else he needs to add
um to help with the tinnitus and keeping
it at his semi low budget
okay well tonight is has to do with
ringing in the ears and it's it's
um the skull squeezing the auditory
branch of the ace cranial nerve he needs
to get a hold of our little book that's
very cheap it's very cheap little book
on the CD set it's on your head there's
a chapter for each thank you there's a
chapter for each of the cranial nerves
and so chapter eight in this book
okay and also in the CD that comes along
with it uh we'll tell him what's going
on there because of tinnitus okay and so
what he needs to do is work very hard to
get rid of all the bad stuffs it's going
to
mess around with absorption no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils or
gluten no eating butter around oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbonate or
drinks you know the diet drinks got to
go and also the carbonated water has to
go and then at 220 pounds I'd like to
see him ideally
um but he's going to save a lot of money
by getting her the bad foods bad foods
tend to be very expensive at the 220
pounds for him to really get maximum
benefit here he needs to take
um two of the healthy brand and heart
patch a month but if you can only afford
one goes one Health brand hard pack per
month one bottle a month of the MSM then
I wanted to get one bottle a month pubsy
um let's see here I-26 it could be the
chewables it could be the powder could
be the capsules I like the chewables and
um
that's going to help him
get things under control but he's going
to have to stay away from the bad stuff
so he can absorb the good stuff it
wouldn't hurt for him also to throw in
the collagen of probably I think the
glucaj would be the most economical
glucogel as they're a collagen he could
take two or three of those twice a day
every two miles a month of the glucogel
that's going to help him rebuild
cartilage and ligaments and tendons
connective tissue disc between
vertebrate bone rate bone itself
including the skull because the skull is
with squeezing the auditory branch of
the atrial nerve is why he has his
terrible tinnitus okay
okay thank you Dr Waller you bet
all right thank you Ruth Allen and Dr
Wallach on that glucogel because the
ringing in the ears is one of the things
that I was able to put behind me I was
taking five three times a day
his ring in the ears was only part of
the side effects that I was having from
that osteoporosis of the skull so five
three times a day and it just did
wonders
it's amazing what giving your body what
it needs
I have two questions for you Dr Wallach
before we go one let's talk Sickle Cell
sickle cell anemia
so I have a one of my coaches has a
client
um whose son is 13 years old
he is at 13 years old he's only 95
pounds
um at five foot one
and
he has sickle cell anemia and it seems
to have affected you know his whole body
the mom is wanting to know is there
anything that they can do because
they're considering a bone marrow
transplant
in fact they've got one scheduled for
next week
so bone marrow is where our blood is
made what happens when you transplant it
is that fixing the problem
well
um what it does is it gives you a higher
percentage of normal cells to make red
blood cells uh when you have sickle cell
anemia mama was missing stuff when the
embryo is farming
okay mama was missing stuff and the
embryo was farming and so the cells in
the bone marrow that make red blood
cells were damaged and so they just make
more damage red blood cells from the
baby's born okay it's not a genetic
thing it's a nutritional deficiency at
the embryonic stage okay when when the
bone marrow is forming
what they want to do is put more
healthy bone marrow cells in the bone
marrow to make more healthy red blood
cells as opposed to having a bigger
percentage of damage
bone marrow cells which make more of the
of sickle cell anemia cells okay let me
go to cells and so that's that's how
they have learned how to deal with this
but
um it's still whether they go ahead with
the transplant or not that's up to them
but it's not a genetic thing this kid
when he grows up and he's a father he
can have all his babies could be normal
not no single cell anemia if the mother
is taking all the 90 essential nutrients
before she gets pregnant
okay because it's not a genetic thing
so I hope that answers all the questions
so that does help but okay so if if Mama
didn't have what she needed whenever the
baby was being formed and sickle cell
was a result of it
does the baby then have the or now a
teenager
just replacing the bone marrow is that
going to fix the problem is the
underlying problem still going to be
there with the nutrition well what
you're doing instead of having 90 of
your cells bad
you may only have 50 of the cells bad so
if you have more normal red blood cells
and less sickle cell
red blood cells
okay so are you saying sickle cell is
going to be a forever thing it just
depends on
well it just depends well it depends how
much they're going to take every
are they going to take every cell out of
his bone marrow and throw it away and
put all new cells in his bone marrow
then that he won't have any Sickle Cell
cells but he'll go from say
35 40 percent 60 Sickle cells does say
maybe 10 Sickle cells or the bone marrow
transplant
because they're dealing with
okay so then replacing the bone marrow
helps to change
sickle cell the number no it just
changes the numbers so instead of having
75 percent of his red blood cells Sickle
cells he might only have a five percent
or ten percent because that's the ratio
that they've created by putting in
normal cells in there and taking out the
cells
that are sickled
okay so the surgery is going to improve
the issue improve the situation is
nutrition needed of course
you have to take care of the new cells
just like they should have taken care of
those cells in the embryo
okay okay so you should still get anemia
with the transplant if you're not taking
in all the nutrients you need to give
your bone marrow what it needs to make
normal red blood cells
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
that's what I wanted to hear
so now let's go over to Sherry who has a
great question Sherry go ahead and
unmute yourself
thank you the question that came in is
what can we do to protect ourselves from
the ryzen TB and polio in New York City
okay well the rise of polio and tea and
tuberculosis TV okay in New York City
has to do with people
who are
um how to work
they're not eating right their immune
systems are down they're living on the
streets so people who have sickle excuse
me people who have tuberculosis and and
those kinds of things will be spreading
it to people who have very low immune
systems because they're eating junk food
or
garbage or whatever it is and so that's
what's going on there
they can take a colloidal silver which
will kill viruses bacteria fungus and
yeast
um but you don't you don't but I do I
take close over
a minimum of three times mostly four
times a day I'll take it say 10 minutes
for each meal and Tim is um uh after I
wake up in the morning okay our
colloidal silver two droppers fall under
my tongue and the silver kills viruses
bacteria fungus and yeast and all that
kind of stuff
and it's kind of like living in an
antibiotic World okay and they've been
doing that for thousands of years as
Colonial Silver's been used for over 2
000 years so it's not like it's
something new and you don't need a
prescription you don't need to have your
doctor's write a prescription for it we
make it available
um uh and so it comes in a dropper
bottle
and I think it's four ounces what the
bottles are and I go that's correct I go
through two of those bottles a month two
to the four ounce bottles a month
um
of the collo silver that's just part of
my regimen and it's tasteless there's no
alcohol in it you can put on an open
wound it doesn't burn because there's no
alcohol in it it tastes like water looks
like water
all right thank you so much you bet
yes thank you for a great question
um Sherry so Dr Wallach I have a
question kind of to piggyback off of
that and I know that we're running short
on time so my mom and all four of her
sisters got polio from the polio vaccine
the polio was contagious correct
well it was a virus
it's a virus so
if if people even people that are not
living on the streets
can get it if they come in contact oh
absolutely if your immune system is down
and you contact somebody with active
open polio infection and they sneeze on
you or spit on you or sweat on you or
whatever and you get those viruses
um and your immune system isn't working
well you can wind up with polio okay
it's an infectious disease and so this
is one of the reasons why you need to be
taking all your 90 essential nutrients
stay away from the bad foods maximize
absorption you know lower the
inflammation levels and all that kind of
stuff
and then you're protecting yourself
um and of course a lot of people don't
want to get vaccinations now and so
forth which is everybody's Choice that's
fine but whether you're getting
vaccinations or not you still need to be
taking all 90 essential nutrients stay
away from the bad stuff so you can
maximize absorption you're going to do
everything you can to support your
body's ability to defend itself maintain
itself repair itself
and reproduce healthy babies live a long
time why would you want to die if 75
that's it right now that's the life
expectancy of Americans is 75. everybody
in America should be able to live to be
120 like the hundreds they don't even
have medical doctors their their life
expectancy season 120. we have the best
medical doctors in the world just ask
them we're the best medical donors in
the world yet are life expectancy in
America well documented even bragged
upon by the doctors is 75. now which
number is bigger Becca
75 or 120
120. okay so I'm going to do what the
hundreds are doing and they're getting
all these minerals from their
glacial milk they live in the land
flowing with milk and honey it's not
cow's milk or goat's milk it's glacial
milk
and because you're getting all those
nutrients in the glacial milk and that's
chapter 10 of my book Rare Earth
manicures chapter 10 the whole chapter
goes into that of the whole thing
um how you can add 25 to 50 Health years
your life
by taking our
minerals okay
and so this is why we do we do if you
have people you have people who are
unconscious pastors who are unconscious
for six weeks you just rubbed it on
their body absorbed it through their
body and they got well we actually have
you know cool CD praise the Lord and
Pastor 90. okay that's Pastor Mike
Freeman from Baltimore Maryland okay
you're supposed to die the doctor said
he only had hours to live and here it is
10 years later he's doing very well
thank you all those doctors
yep well Dr Wally thank you so much for
that we appreciate your time each and
every day and it is time for you to move
on to your next event
we'll see you tomorrow okay thank you
thank you so much Becca thank you team
bye-bye everybody
hi doc
all right thank you everybody for
hanging out with us for the last 53
minutes and if I could just get my
co-hosts on with me
um I greatly appreciate that because I
greatly appreciate them I could not do
this program without them
um folks if you are listening there's a
reason why you're listening did this
speak to you
or did it make you think of somebody
else that this message could be
beneficial for
there's a lot of things that we as
individuals can do on our own to help
ourselves in this journey we call life
and in this journey we have called life
we have more control over it than a
medical system wants us to believe or
even know is possible
we are not chemical deficient or
nutrient deficient you correct those
nutritional deficiencies the body has a
better capability of
thriving
not just barely surviving
I want to thank my co-hosts with me Ruth
Ellen Sanchez for all that she does and
helping to make sure everything goes
smoothly letting me know when people
aren't where they're supposed to be or
uh yeah
I get this
type thing
um so I'm glad that you can't see it but
I'm very much appreciated or she's very
much appreciated and Marilyn also and I
also saw that Sherry she was helping put
information into the chat folks that's
one of the advantages of being live with
us is being able to sing that chat
because of HIPAA rules and everything we
do not have that on our broadcasts we
want to protect those who are here with
us
um and make sure that their information
is not being presented to the masses
also so thank you so much Marilyn for
all of your dictation and and the
summary that you send me after the show
so appreciated and Sherry for helping
let people in and also putting things in
the chat keeping an eye on the gallery
and making sure those who have cameras
on are doing it in a respectful Manner
and the same with Albert and making sure
that people are getting in so they can
hear the message and ask their questions
also and Coach rod and AJ both part of
the technical team and making sure
everything is going smoothly greatly
appreciate them
um
and and keeping an eye on on the room
too so they're my bouncers
yeah they my virtual protection
everybody you have been watching daily
with Doc we are a group of certified
holistic health coaches who really have
a passion and desire to see people reach
their optimal best
we are only a small group of an amazing
community and if you were shared by
somebody specific
to watch this program whether you're
here live or watching the replay let us
know put in the comments
who shared this program with you where
you're watching from and share share
share share like our channels subscribe
to our channels go to our website daily
withdoc.com subscribe for our newsletter
if you would like a and I'm going to
offer this folks if you would like a
free 15-minute consultation and you have
never spoken to anybody before
I am offering up my team for that free
15-minute consultation now if you have
spoken to somebody there's going to be a
charge I'm not going to lie to you
because my guys
and gals
are worth more than what they charge
when it comes to doing consultations the
value that they bring into your life is
as very
Priceless actually but anyways
15-minute free consultations for those
of you who have never spoken to anybody
about Dr Wallach youngevity or haven't
tried the products you may call
855-949-3377 or go to our website use
that contact us and send us a message
letting us know that you are interested
in a free consultation and we will make
sure that we get you with somebody
preferably in your time zone so as
you're doing that request let us know
what time zone you are in and if you
have any special needs that you would
like to hook up with somebody that has
experience with that situation and put
that in your email to us as well
I think I got everything
yeah I got the good I got the nod so
thank you so much again for joining us
my name is Becca dukes and as the
hostess of this program and also
director of student services for The
Institute of holistic health again if
you are interested in becoming a
certified holistic health coach go to
coachwithdoc.com and get more
information and sign up today bye for
now
recording stopped
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]